this week we've got killer kindness oh
yes Africa on repeat and endless
macaroni oh I love macaroni really
mm-hmm just the macaroni plain no no no
I like the concept of it anything on it
of the pasta I like hugs like a rainbow
like elbow yeah and I call it's like the
rainbow tunnel mm-hmm like little pipes
yeah like how the sauce gets stuck in
there and then you squish it out yeah my
favorite daycare snack was the macaroni
and cheese with sliced hot dogs we'll
get to that later the ghetto bomb stuff
because Michelin stars what's the first
story about Tim thanks Mickey the first
story is about this drunk man who
threatened to kill his neighbors with
kindness easy okay um what he was
arrested after he attacked a man with
the machete that had the word kindness
ready I see what you did there kill him
what crime every time I hear someone
like goes and tries to like assault
someone with a machete I'm [ __ ]
horrified if I hear something with like
a knife or whatever I'm like damn that's
[ __ ] up but not oh I'm not horrified
say machete the right way though my
Danny Trejo every time he movie with the
phone up her [ __ ] huh you don't watch
them build the intro yeah but in the end
she pulls a cell phone out of her vagina
sure she's butt naked how come how come
you're horrified of people attacking
with knives and stuff cuz it's so nice
it's gruesome machete specifically like
hacking away at someone yeah that part
of it cuz it's like so it's like so
primal and so [ __ ] Savage who had a
machete was a Jason or Michael or one of
those creepy guys like the probably dude
tipsybartender cut his leg open with the
machete by accident coconut house first
started working with him he was
sharpening it in a video and he was like
talking about how sharp it is now
finally got a sharpener and
cuts through him in an ambulance because
he like accidentally cut his leg open
gnarly like it was all cut open and he's
still editing in the hospital he's like
I'm not gonna slip on my schedule damn
people like that make me feel really bad
about myself cuz I wasn't I would just
not upload for the next three months oh
yeah I lost my leg dude I'm done
cancel did cancel the show cancel I'm
cancelled you just can't wait for
something to happen
my cat sick web got canceled you don't
have a cat David I do now not only that
the cats out to eat a pizza yeah
everything goes to [ __ ] I need to be
consoled I adopt the cat and I gave it
poison it's calling him got an excuse I
just don't feel like it I don't feel
like it
yes this man his name is Brian Brian
he's 30 years old from Florida look how
cute he is too I like his mugshot yeah
it looks like he's pouting it's
shoulders [ __ ] [ __ ] is that from the
fight what yeah so he was drunk oh and
the police was trying to subdue him but
yeah so that's why I just he ended up
getting all scruffles death does Florida
have like a meth problem
everything problem it was a bath salts
they like bath salts where zombies were
they were eating people's faces off yes
Abhi's cannibal yeah
but am told yeah so he ended up saying
he was gonna kill his neighbors with
kindness after there was a neighbor who
came over and said like hey Oh cuz this
dude was just screaming in his house by
himself and in his own house
yeah you know just like hey you know can
you keep it down like what's wrong like
what's happening and then so he just got
really upset because of that sand this
other neighbor came over to try that
like help calm things down cuz he was
getting riled up and that's when that
second neighbor came over and he ended
up giving him a half inch gash on his
left hand
yeah yeah half-inch deep I don't know
you just said yeah I think deep cuz yeah
because if it's a half inch this way
that's who the [ __ ] cares but if the
half inch deep
that's [ __ ] some [ __ ] I think that
should it's gushing you know if if
people aren't going on jungle excursions
like why do you need a machete because
they're pretty awesome they're dull
they're [ __ ] dope to have it's a
great camping tool to instead of axe
okay okay cuz I I mean I always see that
to swap me garden cellar or whatever and
I'm always wondering like what they use
it cut you can cut branches on there
yeah gardening just in case you hey no
not the one i have the one i have it's a
curved one in his last she died and you
just and it has a sawing in for the
other good the way it's weighted it hits
branches and the branches fall out just
looks like a big scary night dude watch
naked and afraid it's gonna make you
want how much at they so bad like it's
so [ __ ] useful dude did you guys ever
see that video of its some something
similar to this the drunk neighbor goes
over to one of his neighbor's house and
then that full soul fed up as seeing
this [ __ ] drunk guy on his yard that
he just gets a [ __ ] high-powered
water hose he's just starting up I just
love you cuz he like wants to spray him
off his lawn but that was so wasted I
see and he just stands there it's pretty
funny I don't like this yeah it's load
you'd like the way the [ __ ] sparks
are firing was the last time you guys
been drunk like that
ooh spatula a long-ass time ago been a
minute why are you yak like a
[ __ ] yeah you were in there no I
was not last week you were that I drink
one bottle of modelo and I had the best
time folding laundry yeah you couldn't
get off of me it's a nickname for years
of things folding laundry what's called
in my line I suppose
gratefully holdin her in half a teeny
little piece comfortable [ __ ] you know
we had sex
I'm Ella but we don't like it I know too
much about your sex life I know we got
to show you our nest
our cameras are called mesh not that's
that it's like our nest footage I know
you still have it facing your bed even
though teca's out there you all forget
add row nah you'll see my book and hide
and seek videos at icon it did they're
awesome
that's all we have those so I can see
the little [ __ ] walking around
and still hey Chris I'll show you I'm
good dramatize this whole room is
traumatized she's so polite still though
she's like no good the door purpose for
sex and tight though we got it for
burglars no I don't think it's for the
burglars
no that song the Africa bite oh yeah
yeah that was some time ago Fred it's a
meme now
it was stuck in my head forever and song
is it I'm good like I could play it in
my head but I can't forget my tweezer
right and then that kind of yeah we
that's why it started surfacing again oh
it started surfacing again because it
was a meme like rickrolled Pato really
cuz they just Weezer just released it
like I don't know what came first but
for sure the meme was much more popular
okay so this song is not gonna be
playing forever on an endless eternal
loop in Africa oh oh that sucks
oh just speakers everywhere all the
animals are gonna see what if you're
lost in there and you're like I can't
get away from this book just why would
they do that so this is an art
installation or sound I said the lyrics
just now what are they of us the planes
down and Africa or maybe I bless the
rains but I can't remember it's like us
with planes or the rains I bust the
plane both the pip-boy got much rain so
I've watched the planes down in ass
bless black here we go this is what the
sound insulation looks like in sound
whoosh oh it's beautiful that's just in
the middle and then man oh my god wait
it's on it just sounded like it was blue
it's this drone person walking person
was oh okay I'm boy yo my mind just got
blown bro prevent people from stealing
that's how I was about to say I'm like
that shit's only gonna last I I thought
that [ __ ] was drone footage of a
building that they built into Destin
[ __ ] mind is blown right now dude
well perception is everything you
thought it was a skyscraper picket cords
on the planet yeah like a telephone wire
or whatever electrical lines and no
windows in the suits of prison I thought
it was like an art piece but you thought
your massive skyscraper says he thought
the artists tried harder than he really
did yeah because there's nothing in
relation to show the size of it yeah so
which is it in the middle of the Sahara
no it would not be desert okay I don't
know what the place looks beautiful
yeah so this artist he his name is Max
side and top sounds good Swedish sure
I'm being nambian he's from nambia yeah
mo bien
so he's 27 years old and he expects it
so he chose an undisclosed spot
obviously he's not broadcasting do this
guy sounds like a STONER like what if we
play the African song in the middle
Africa forever
yeah it's couple in it oh I'll put my
ipod out there with a speaker yeah so he
set it up with six speakers attached an
mp3 player with just that one song on it
and he expects it to keep going for
another 55 in solar-powered is a
solar-powered house the anacott
solar-powered weather resistant yes it
just doesn't seem amazing to me now
because I thought it was a building now
I was like whatever did it know it was
some dudes amp and I applaud I thought
they were trying to create like you know
the [ __ ] Stonehenge thing that's why
the thing was a lot bigger in my mind it
looks like if they get us a [ __ ] what
is a Desert Storm or whatever that it's
gonna knock everything over yeah like
one gust of wind would not get all over
and isn't that lightweight offensive for
there to be a song about Africa in
English well I don't know he's African
himself Oh is equal [ __ ] that guy that
all right
oh not the musician but the guy who made
it no there's a white dude that did that
the art it oh the band is white okay no
I thought the white guy that installed
that he made white pillars
in Africa so you [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
this story is making me dumber I'll tell
you something cool though the Sahara
Desert is almost the size of the United
States of a marker wait what you it's
massive yeah so how do you pronounce
this is n a mid-90s I'm making it up it
Namie be I mean okay thank you everyone
else I don't know I can't hold on mask
it sounds like that would be correct I
mean nah me desert
I said nom B which is wrong Oh nom
because you said number two my bad okay
I don't care next up it in Nam be okay
confusion confusion let's go it's next
to boss no he never listens to me
don't call her a [ __ ] and see what she
says what I don't know I was on this
like roller coaster a [ __ ] high right
now
you [ __ ] [ __ ] back now say something
back
okay so our four last story now you can
tell us about your mac and cheese
because now we're talking about mac and
cheese let's go back to the hot dog mac
and cheese again I already said it all
well here I'll contribute to that
conversation I actually did not like mac
and cheese until I was like in high
school well I think I really didn't like
it and so the only way I ever knew about
mac and cheese was from the box that
cheese tasted so funky to me I think I
didn't even like cheese until high
school I don't even know what magic it
came from we would just get like these
little paper balls and then the day care
lady would cancel because you were
eating [ __ ] saltine crackers with
banana I like the box mac and cheese
because my grandma would do it with she
would put ground beef and onions first
Oh pepper garlic and [ __ ] and then she
would make and then she would fold that
into the mac and cheese she was so
[ __ ] good rest in peace grandma yeah
I thought that was cheese like cuz that
was my reference point of what cheese
West so when we go to the restaurants
and they make mac and cheese with real
cheese I was like what is this I hate it
this is not that good she's a good kid
thing yeah thank you it's whatever you
like grew up with and you saw that's the
truth exactly yeah that's like the
gourmet [ __ ] everything else is a phony
mac and cheese is quite delicious it's
just so bad for you I just started
liking it right now right like today
this moment no no like we sing oh okay
we do it down to buy so the what we're
talking about here is the fact that
Costco sells a 27 pound tub of macaroni
cheese that will last you for 20 years
what anakata $90 cancel it's a hundred
and eighty servings but guess what
they're all sold well cuz they only made
two don't try to [ __ ] fluff up your
numbers I mean like fine we're so you
can't fool damn yeah we made or you
three me oz pre-made Lord what is that
oh you get a sample Steve would buy that
right if we got a sample and he liked it
he needs it for to feed his kidney
stones yeah is it like from their
ready-made aisle like where they have
all the chicken and all that stuff like
it's already made yeah
yeah yeah probably they didn't mention
that but no no like that you know how
they have a chicken the rotisserie
chicken belly and all that yeah that's a
lot of commitment though might just be
in the refrigerator admit that's like a
mortgage you know like you I don't can't
commit to a food for that long
that's disgusting what about big parties
chefs banquet yeah big parties no oh
that would make 187 that doesn't except
then you could have 20 you're part
through yes this one maybe schools
should buy it
the Fresh Market cheese though man
that's the [ __ ] no I'm fee I'm [ __ ]
making lunch for my kids but yeah my
when I was going to school I we didn't
get lunch I had eat that [ __ ] true oh I
got packed to lunch and I wish that I
could eat the cafeteria food cuz like oh
that's what everyone else did no I threw
all my food away all got cold mac and
cheese no I'm saying I was the kid that
got that ate the cafeteria food my
mother my mom never made me lunch oh
yeah thank God no my mom cooks I know
but the school I just bought it is good
that's what I'm saying that's what I
love you it depends on what school you
went to I think my school mom to me
because I didn't get a lot of American
food at the house that's what that's
what it is yeah no my house food was
bomb and that [ __ ] was garbage I'm like
Oh have you tried combining them it
would have been bomber oh yeah I can't
it's little compartment oh I'm opposite
I like that's this guy oh yeah taco boat
and then what was your mom give you what
do you mean for lunch nothing Oh what
does she cook at home right cactus slice
up the fried cactus put on the top she
when she wouldn't pack it for me I just
stayed at home that's what I'm saying
imagine you combine all of it holy
what would you do then you wouldn't eat
cafeteria food but you also didn't have
packed lunch I probably just waited but
I mean that's how do I forget to eat now
damn you rather not eat instars yeah I
ate foods that you don't like right yep
I was I need anything I was such a not
picky eater
no I was parfum milk you didn't like
milk I hated milk ham sausage bacon and
what in the [ __ ] is wrong with that's a
Denver omelet that you just hated right
now
do you eat it now she legit you said I
hate Debora off would you have against
Colorado Oh
legally they legalized weed
you don't like milk you didn't like eggs
I didn't like no I did like milk ham
sausage pepperoni and he's like any Pig
thug didn't like mayo and those are the
I love male 2 now yeah it's so grown my
mouth is like my second penis well I got
a jacket off a [ __ ] picture to me
brother Jack my mouth off with
McDonald's macaroni ins picture him with
a hot dog oh yeah me too
[ __ ] you know what I made it I made
these Korean corn dogs [ __ ] man oh
yeah I got the invitation that's right
what's Korean corn dogs if you've ever
gotten to Korea they have like their
version of like corn dog like street
foods and obviously you could do with it
whatever sausage you want is it fresh
video you showing us yeah so it's on me
it's deep-fried we don't use cornmeal
it's just flour but they crust it with
Pinkel breadcrumbs yummy and then you
put sugar on it so it's like yeah
there's like a corn dog mixed with like
a beignet put together oh no no no no no
yeah and then the corn dog history
because it's a pancake batter right
a montecrisco or Montecristo have you
ever had that yeah it's kind of
something like that it's it's really
good though and you add the pinko crumbs
on top where you get this at he made it
you can get one you actually have a spot
in k-town why didn't you invite us what
we're doing it's pretty good though I
think you're doing a fake friend I think
you always like bake yeah like you
always tell us about all these dope
things that you do outside of the circle
and I'm like wait a minute did you get
an invite no did you how cool this
Huntington Library must be oh very cool
it was cold as [ __ ] that day he didn't
miss me mom it was probably warm with
all the body he put my friends that were
there from all the warmth from the heart
yeah would you guys like to do a corndog
party yeah
you don't know how much I love corn dog
really corn dogs are the [ __ ] especially
I love hot dogs and corn dogs oh my god
I didn't know that about you I love it
I'll get you a bottle of my favorite one
is hot dog on a stick so sometimes I go
to the mall just to get a corn dog from
Hot Dog on a Stick big [ __ ] Cinnabon
mmm or auntie Annie's pretzels - it's
good - man you're a junkie
[Music]